that's a man's job and I want to hear
your thoughts on that particular phrase
so remember just oppose their views it's
super simple right uh there are men's
jobs and there are women's jobs I mean I
think we we all I mean we're not saying
that that doesn't exist right I mean
you're not we are kind we are kind of
saying
that but it's just like if you pull up
to a garage and you got to get like an
alternator replaced and there's a woman
mechanic the majority of men and women
are going to look at that and be like
hey man I'm all for you know women's
rights I mean who isn't but I also want
my car to run
well you can feel it you can feel it I
can't take it what is this what am I
watching like what is this show I don't
so much of the stuff that just pops up
in my feed I don't even know where it
comes from I guess he makes broadly
decent points though not not the most
gracefully articulated but